[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we're going to be talking about
and actually following Kendall Jenner's
alleged diet but first we're going to
play a little game called Abby's daily
hunger crushing combo so tonight's
little bedtime snack is going to be a
favorite of mine I'm going to warm up
one of my favorite build bars this is
the coconut brownie chunk
and she is so good coming out of that
microwave let me show you okay
um smells like a chocolate coconut
brownie
we're gonna
take this to the next level okay A
little drizzle for some healthy fats
and top her off with a couple berries on
the side
that's our fiber
and now we dig in
[Music]
trust me guys the melted she just hits
different you guys know I'm obsessed
with these build bars because they are
packed with protein this one's got 15
grams of protein per bar but it tastes
like chocolate because it's made with
chocolate and chocolate when melted is
fire so if you want to try a build bar
for yourself you can check out the link
in the description and use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and before we get into it a quick
disclaimer that this diet was compiled
from multiple secondary sources where
she was quoted or close contact was
quoted which is not exactly scientific
research or even perfect journalism
so I'm not suggesting that these are her
actual meals but as always with my
wedding a day videos it doesn't really
matter here because my commentary is not
really about Kendall's actual diet I'm
using these alleged meals as a template
just for teaching gentle nutrition and
that goes without saying that my meals
here are not meant to serve as a
suggestion of how you should eat so
always speak to a registered dietitian
about your unique needs also don't
forget to hit that subscribe button we
love to see you guys coming back and
follow me over on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen all right
let's dive in and get some Jenner
Kardashian approved food so according to
Harper's Bazaar Kendall likes to do her
workout around 7 00 a.m which we love to
see because I'm also a morning girl and
she prefers resistance training to
cardio me too because [ __ ] running uh my
pelvic floor is too far gone for that
and she apparently does a lot of ab
exercises to stay lean
folks doing ab workouts all day is not
the key to looking lean we have lots of
evidence suggesting that you can't just
like spot reduce fat in your midsection
from doing sit-ups alone even if you
have very strong abdominal muscles you
need to break down the fat on top of
those muscles to see AB definition which
may require a combination of resistance
training and cardio and of course your
diet so yeah I'm gonna do a standard
full body workout because planking for
30 minutes sounds boring as
foreign
[Music]
okay so maybe I wasn't feeling a full
body workout today uh I did a sampling
of a full body workout just a taste but
I just got to listen to my body today
and I know that I'm just not feeling any
kind of hardcore workout so I'm good and
I'm ready to eat so according to E news
uh Kendall likes to start her day with
detox tea 12.
cups of it that's a hard pass friends
you do not need to drink detox tea heart
stop you have a liver kidneys sweat
glands lungs and intestines to detox
your body naturally every day and yeah
any tea will help support your body's
natural detox capacity because it's
99.9999999999999999 percent water and
water makes you pee AKA detox but some
detox Blends can actually be dangerous
in excess some contain herbal laxatives
which can cause diarrhea nausea and
stomach cramps short term and
electrolyte imbalance liver damage and
lacks of dependence long term there are
actual case studies of this happening
and it's Bad News Bears and this is why
you're really not supposed to take
laxatives for more than a week your body
might just kind of like forget how to
poop and naturally carry out its
detoxifying jobs not to mention there
are no known benefits from a weight or
fat loss perspectives to detox tea aside
from the hypothetical loss of some water
weight from diarrhea hard pass from me
so yeah I'm going to continue on with my
coffee and just drink some regular old
tap water
Nature's detoxing calls so according to
our now defunct app in 2017 she was
quoted as saying I don't really cook
much other than my standard eggs avocado
and toast breakfast I also read in
another interview with she finds that
her trainer said that she always has
avocado eggs and oats so it seems like
she's really into the egg avocado and
carb combo which we love to see because
it's a built-in amazing hunger crushing
combo so I'm basically just going to
tweak this to my taste and like sneak in
a little extra fiber and protein let's
make breakfast
so here's my little haxies
we got
some avocado and like a handful of white
beans
I'm just going to add some extra protein
and fiber lemon juice
just to
add a little extra zing and also prevent
Browning
Masher yeah
if you want this to be like super
deliciously smooth you can put in a food
processor but I just don't have time
poor interests feel like I'm
Alice in Wonderland
because I
was
fabulous
okay salt and pepper
good
there you go it's a great way to stretch
a small avocado too
we love that
out
from the day got some big old pieces of
bread this is
a large piece it's going to be one or
two why not two
this is not fitting in my toaster
is there a point of this
question mark
what would Kendall Jenner use
she'd probably use this just to flip so
let's give it a go friends
spread that that boy around oh my gosh I
picked this up to be like
I actually don't know what I was
thinking I'm
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
me not my day at home
oh did you hear those cracks
[ __ ] me I'm getting old old and very
much out of it where are we going to
all right let's get some salt and pepper
love on these
they kind of got curled up so they can
be like toast boats and
what was I gonna do everything bagel
we're gonna basic [ __ ] this up with
some everything bagel spice
let's get our avocado mixture down I'll
divide the love
I'm just gonna lay it over the bed of
bread it's like twin beds with an egg
just like starfished across the beds
that's how I the laziest egg the laziest
egg of Life where's my cheese where my
cheese at look at that Yoki Yoki
um
love a Sourdough moment we got our eggs
in there for our protein and we got fat
in there too plus avocado for fiber and
healthy fats and the white beans that I
snuck in as well which just bump up the
protein and fiber delicious so balanced
and obviously super satiating as well
Kendall you know what you're doing girl
we love it all right so for lunch
Kendall's been quoted in Harper's Bazaar
saying that she likes lean chicken brown
rice and vegetables so basically like
the standard clean eating celebrity diet
but I was personally way more interested
in her favorite salad from the
restaurant health nut which is
apparently the deluxe salad with chicken
hold the Tomato so when I looked this up
honestly the pitcher kind of looked like
one of those really old school salads
that you'd get at like a basic Deli I
don't know maybe it's the optional scoop
of tuna salad that gives it that Vibe
but that's kind of where my head was
going Kendall goes with the chicken
instead which is what I prefer anyways
but I still do feel like it's a bit of a
blah boring salad I was just really
happy to see that she's keeping the
cheese in there because I love cheese as
I know that Kendall has been quoted as
saying that she tries to limit her
consumption of dairy to help keep her
skin clear I started thinking about my
diet a lot and and um decided to cut out
Dairy I love cheese so it's hard for me
to cut out cheese and that honestly
helped me so much so Kendall is not
alone in choosing a dairy-free life or
clear skin and I've talked about this in
more detail here but some research does
support this one 2018 review found that
people who consumed dairy milk were 60
percent more likely to have acne than
those who did not and another larger few
had similar results meanwhile a 2016
review found only a weak Association now
it's important to note that this is all
correlational data and very
individualized as well so not everyone
is going to break out when they consume
milk I love Dairy and it has no impact
on my skin and it's also worth noting
that a lot of the research has actually
focused on younger teens so it is hard
to know if this is directly transferable
to people at different hormonal stages
of life but of course if you find that
removing Dairy from your diet helps your
skin and amazing you unlocked the secret
that's great if it works for you it
works and I would say if you are
struggling with hormonal acne and aren't
sure what the cause is it is worth
experimenting with your diet to just
take a look to see so this is my salad
and I don't have acne I really never
have had acne and I really like cheese
even though I feel like shredded
mozzarella is probably the most
flavorless cheese not feeling it so I'm
going with feta instead which I much
prefer but let's chop some of the
essential veggies in her salad first we
got some romaine
thank you
I'm gonna shred up
a carrot
chunk of carrot in my throat
right
carrots in cucumber
this is the way
that feels better
for some reason she doesn't eat tomatoes
but I like tomatoes so we're gonna add
those bad boys back in
foreign
Tomatoes can be challenging
Kendall prefers the chicken to the tuna
me too girl me
too
so the deluxe salad has sunflower seeds
and I'm adding feta because
shredded mozzarella has a zero flavor
this looks like a good salad man
like imma eat that
just got a simple vinaigrette here from
my fridge
a little bit of you a little bit of you
a little bit of you
I'd be excited about that
but
that's not enough for a meal for me your
girl needs some carbs so I got a whole
grain pita pocket slice that in half
nice
dinner up
oops
that smear some Pumas
and open without it getting all
broken
there we go
there we go
there we go
love that noise and then
you give her a little Tossy toss
hello
stuffer in
get in there
all right oh run away get in there this
looks so good just gonna start with some
fruit
cherries some wild bloops and
strawberries gotta eat them before my
kids do because they are a hot commodity
around here
okay lots of fiber rich veg obviously
here in the salad we've got protein from
the chicken we've got some fiber rich
carbs in the whole grain wrap plus all
of our fruit we got healthy fats in the
dressing plus the hummus and the cheese
and the sunflower seeds this is a
delicious and balanced lunch
um
polka
okay so according to Kendall for snacks
she loves guac and chips and carrots and
hummus which are two of my favorite
go-to snack pairings of all time but I
feel like if I pair
Heather it will have a amazing super
snack so that's what we're gonna do okay
so this might seem unorthodox but don't
knock it till you try because the combo
is Bomb okay so hummus has some Fiber
some protein and some fats that's going
down and guacamole has fiber and healthy
fats
so we're going to mix them together it's
going to be like an avocado hummus and
like
come on what's wrong with that
all right
that's going down we got
some more fiber
and our carrots
and some chips for our fun and when I
dip you dip we dip
best of all the worlds
okay so for dinner it seems like Kendall
likes to enjoy a wide variety of foods
I've seen her quoted as saying that she
loves to go get sushi and pizza and in
and out basically all the good things in
life so I love that but I was most
intrigued by her signature dish which
she describes as the dish that I cook
better than anyone else we shall see
Kendall we shall see so I found this
recipe for her lemon parmesan fettuccine
on People magazine and it sounds
okay
I mean it's not calling for like any
butter or oil or any sauce here so like
I feel like it's gonna be a little dry
um so yeah I'm gonna add a little bit of
oil to start to cook things like in the
least we also have to chop an onion so
let's start with that
I need practice with the onions five
hours later add some salt
all right water
so I'm using chickpea pasta because this
recipe doesn't actually have any protein
added to it but I figure it's a great
way to sneak in some extra protein and
some Fiber as well
is it rolling
oh I think I think I think that's
rolling
she rolling rolling with the homies
oh okay so this recipe does not call for
asparagus
but
I feel like asparagus and peas and lemon
are just like a natural pairing so it's
kind of essential so I'm just gonna cut
some of these up
add it in
oh
we don't want that
oopsie okay so this calls for like a
whole bag of peas that's a ton of peas
like are we eating pasta or are we
eating peas so I'm just gonna like
still have these and split the
difference
so it's plenty
well I cannot wait too easily
that tongue
[Music]
you know you're on 90s kid when
subscribe to my only fans for the best
news
and it says we need
quarter cup of Reggiano
so I'm going to eyeball that
slash add as much cheese and the desires
[Music]
and it says add a little bit
of the pasta water
to just make a little sauce
Plus
do we need lemon zest
or just lemon juice just lemon juice
all I can say is it's going to need a
hell of a lot more cheese than a quarter
cup
salt
peps
mess
and more cheese
you're grating that she's so weird
I know I am sorry you're right why are
this yeah that's why
there we go this is a better way
this is the way you know what this could
use
like an egg yolk
let's make it like a carbonara Stitch
actually it's not bad
it's not bad
it's not bad
all right so to make this a more
satisfying satiating meal I'm serving it
with some of the extra salad that I made
for lunch which has some chicken on
there for some extra protein since the
pasta dish here didn't really have any
official kind of like added protein but
I did try to bump it up a little bit
more with the chickpea pasta so we're
getting some protein in there we're
getting some extra fiber I added some
extra vegetables with the asparagus and
I added in some healthy fats with the
olive oil so let's take a little tasty
and it's honestly pretty good the extra
cheese absolutely is necessary otherwise
I'm pretty sure it taste like lemony
carbs
I eat that okay so according to Harper's
Bazaar Kendall's been quoted as saying
I'm obsessed with frozen yogurt I could
eat it every day but I aim for twice a
week as a treat girl you can have Froyo
more than twice a week if it brings you
Joy I'm gonna make it even more
satiating and satisfying by turning into
a hunger crushing combo with some
berries and nuts
let's do it so I just popped some frozen
painted cherries in the microwave which
are like one of my all-time favorite
things
[Applause]
cherries are often just like better than
fresh flavor-wise maybe not texture wise
but definitely in a dessert like this so
I got some vanilla Froyo
oh I'm excited about this
vanilla and cherries and almonds
like classic classic combo and then we
got some crunch Factor here with some
beautiful almonds
so easy so we've got fiber Protein
healthy fats in our nuts plus some extra
fiber in our cherries and lots of
delicious flavor in our Froyo
gotta get that cherry sauce
it is so good
honestly Kendall not a bad day like I'm
not mad about it the Froyo definitely
made up for the kind of boring salad and
the detox tea just kidding nothing's
gonna make up for 12 cups of diarrhea
tea but yeah definitely not the worst
Kardashian diet I've ever seen so if you
guys like this kind of video please
please don't forget to give me the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
who or what you'd like to see me review
next subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]